[Music]
so Tick-Tock nurses aren't dancing
anymore
that's [ __ ] that's covet stuff
now they've been filming themselves
after patients die I've seen a few of
these this is like a trend this is real
here look I'll play one for you this I
saw this because I've seen this before
okay before not but not with her I've
seen another nurse doing this same thing
that's what I'm saying so it's a thing
it's a trend first off smash obviously
yes but now let's play
I'm so sorry it's so loud I don't know
why it's so loud so they're doing The
Tick Tock things oh my God sorry they're
doing The Tick Tock like they put the
music over
I am
shake off you've had five more hours
because it's the beginning of it says
but you're so upset that you lost a
patient today okay but you're so upset
that you set up your phone in the
hallway to take this video on on what's
obviously some sort of a tripod like
selfie stick thing good time to set that
up you were so distraught I give Duke
Masterson credit he retweeted this and
he goes show the other takes
you know there's some other takes right
set the camera up to film herself this
these people are [ __ ]
[Music]
and then also the fact to use
to use such a cheesy awful like you go
girl pop song over it it's just was this
the one you saw
I put my
um
put my arm but I'll show you later
I
am
Unstoppable it's this is you [ __ ]
nurses are so gross ever I mean
everyone's gross but nurses have just
ladies because you're mostly ladies and
in a couple of gay guys
um nurses you've been out of [ __ ]
control for the past couple of years
it's I'm seeing I know there's more but
it's it's one of the grossest Trends
yeah those are two one those are two
different ones okay so there's a there
must be so there's a third one out there
somewhere it's a trend if you find more
guys please send it yeah please send all
of these these people I'm keep
refreshing to see if there's any more
I mean the only other one they have is
the dancing one okay but this is funny
because it's so it's so tasteless
no I think that's that uh black
conservative comedian making fun of them
I forget his name
um is it young Ripper wait what did
somebody do here
this is the Hodge twins
[Music]
[Laughter]
there you go here you go
[Music]
[Laughter]
[ __ ] internet will always be on
repeat that it's so [ __ ] dark and so
hilarious
oh [ __ ] man
that's so [ __ ] great all right
games are worth it like I'm kind of glad
oh no listen listen the memes make
everything worth it in the end right
like there's the internet always
corrects everything
is this coming in front of him
completely out of coffee oh this is good
I lost it today I love this okay hold on
here you go these are the best ones
I am
completely got a coffee in the nurse's
Lounge
you just put on his girlfriend's scrubs
that's what happened yeah those don't
look like they even fit it looks like
it's his girlfriend is a vet tech
[Laughter]
so this girl's just getting roasted nice
yeah put some emotional music over that
you got a viral hit on your hands oh
he's making it look like he's filming
her okay you know the doctor like he's
dressed like a surgeon
[Music]
nice yeah put some emotional music over
that you got a viral hit on your hands
uh you should probably tell the family
now huh
okay see God damn I am so glad you women
are doing this now I I hate that you're
doing it
but I love that everyone else just piles
on and turns it into something like
somebody turn your [ __ ] into
something amazing
I've seen this one
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I sometimes I love the
internet man I swear to God
ah okay what's the chicks Tick Tock name
I want to see if she's actually getting
she's got to be getting [ __ ] roasted
all over the Internet dude not just like
the New York Post wrote an article about
her getting roasted she is are you
serious fried yeah hold on I'll pull it
here her name is
the luck Co the Luke l u k e c o o k
there you go [ __ ] oh yeah The Daily Dot
Atlanta Journal the Atlanta concert
oh my god dude are they defending her no
she's getting posted
mercilessly dragged hold on universally
by everyone on the internet
so you're saying this one of those
things where both sides meet and we're
like this is yeah
most of the world balances where the
actual World heals itself and balances
out New York Post nurse post crying Tick
Tock after patient die Sparks outrage
for exploiting a nurse is facing a wave
of backlash after posting a tick tock
video of herself crying after one of her
patients died Tick Tock user Olivia
underscore Tyler with two r's 33 posted
the emotional video on June 17th
captioned it never gets easier can I can
I just give a call you read the thing
one of the quotes ain't no way the first
thing that came to her mind was to make
a tick tock
lost the basement today States the video
caption is she Paces back and forth in
the hospital hallway the nurse leans
against the wall with her head down
trying to calm herself
Shake It Off you have five more hours
States the clip over the video an
emotional song plays I put
um you know that uh she since deleted
her account but others were quick to
duet the video and post it on Twitter
slamming the healthcare professional for
exploiting her patience and likes and
Views a viral tweet we're posting the
video with a caption oh man can't
believe my patient died let me go make a
tick tock real quick has nearly 14
million views
uh I understand raising Awareness on
difficulties of being a healthcare
professional but it feels like patients
just exploited for likes and Views
there's a lot of other ways to
experience uh this was not very tasteful
imagine walking in the hallway and
seeing this let me set up a camera so I
can cry Andy Scott commented uh is Mike
is my grief and frame somebody equipped
when you were emotionally upset the loss
of a life rightfully so but to draw
attention to yourself so others can say
that you're upset then it's no longer
about the person who died memory but
rather you this is called narcissism oh
no
what Tick Tock couldn't find this
account yeah Connie I just read it you
deleted it
she was hot man she did some other like
old screenshots and Google images from
her videos she's [ __ ] uh she is hot
I say we forgive her guys of course you
would say that come on